we welcome the agreement of an EU turkey
joint action plan to tackle the current
migratory crisis our intensified
meetings with Turkish leaders here in
Brussels Ankara and in New York in the
last couple of weeks were devoted to one
go stemming the migratory flows that go
via Turkey to the EU the action plan is
a major step in this direction still if
I made clear from the very start an
agreement with turkey makes sense only
if it effectively contains the flour
refugees taken to agree to work on an
integrated border management system that
will go beyond the front X mandate in
the coming month the agency will be
developed into a more operational body
our aim is to give frontex the right to
return irregular migrants on its own
initiative and to make it more proactive
in protecting the external borders in
the meantime member states will be ready
to send hundreds more about the guard to
front x and y ESO to secure the hot spot
areas in Greece and Italy third we also
discussed broader challenges in order to
be ready for a new influx of refugees
next year we had the debate on the
future of the Dublin regulation on the
EU border guard system and on the
specific role of hotspots these are all
divisive issues and the goal today was
to have a first serious exchange of
views on them I had one objective today
that was to lead mama states back to the
promises they made on the twenty-third
of September and we are as far as the
total amount of our financial effort in
the refugee domain is concerned we are
lacking two points we billion years and
they promised today that they will
the contribution of the commission that
means money coming from the European
budget and so I do think that this will
be done in the next coming weeks we have
asked the quarry pair and deluxe box
presidency to make sure that the amounts
we are speaking about will come in the
next coming weeks